bill ackman one of the most famous
well-respected investors on wall street
he's lost 430 million or so in about
three months on a netflix stock bet this
is a wild story now first let's take a
look at netflix their stock is
absolutely getting punished netflix is
expected to gain about 2.5 million
subscribers but they lost 200 000
subscribers that's the first time
they've lost subscribers in nearly a
decade they also have about 222 million
paying households but they estimate that
their service is shared with over 100
million additional households 30 million
of them in the united states and canada
who ain't paying to get that password
and so netflix has been down and down
and down for a while now they tumbled 35
at the close in new york earlier this
week making it the worst performing
stock in the s p 500 this year that
stock is now down 62
in 2022 and you can see that it looks
like it's only gonna keep falling
further and further now if we take a
look at exactly what's going on with
bill ackman back in january of 2022 he
came out and he said that pershing
square bought 3.1 million shares of
netflix making them a top 20 holder of
the stock he specifically cited his
admiration for reed hastings and the
company that has been built by reed and
his team at netflix they're delighted
that the market presented them with this
opportunity now i tend to agree reid
hastings is a fantastic entrepreneur the
company that netflix has built is
amazing but sometimes you just get dealt
the wrong hand or your timing's off and
that's exactly what seems to be
happening here with pershing square if
we now go and take a look we can see
that ackman became that top 20 holder
this year but he bought the stock after
it had already started to dip and he
thought that it was going to recover his
fund has lost about 435 million dollars
on more than 3.1 million shares and he
wrote in his letter to shareholders on
wednesday that they're going to get rid
of their position but the fund is still
okay they're only down about two percent
this year in 2022 but here's the thing
years ago everyone was making fun of
bill ackman he got caught up in a bunch
of different shorts that didn't go his
way but bill put his head down he
started to focus and he had back-to-back
record years for returns for 2019 and
2020. he's had a little bit of trouble
finding a target for his spac where he
had over four billion dollars raised and
they haven't completed a merger yet but
i wouldn't bet against bill ackman the
guy continues to win and after multiple
years of record performance seeing
something like this netflix bet most
people would be worried but bill appears
to have learned from past mistakes he's
cutting the position and he's moving on
he's not going to continue to double
triple quadruple down he's not gonna
catch the falling knight that actually
is a sign of maturity and actually of
having some understanding of cut your
losers early and press your winners but
of course regardless of how
sophisticated and intelligent bill and
his team is the internet's gonna have a
field day when they hear that he lost
400 million dollars in three months and
so the memes came out in full force
parikh patel hitting them with here's
bill ackman after looking at his netflix
position and then of course we also have
trungfon hitting us with bill ackman
before his netflix trade and after his
netflix trade regardless of whether you
find the memes funny or not bill
ackman's still one of the best investors
in the world sure he lost 435 million
dollars in three months on the netflix
stock but there's a lot of people who
are laughing who wish that they had his
financial returns in 2019 and 2020.
those record years will keep bill ackman
in business for a long time and i never
bet against entrepreneurs and investors
even if they have a little bit of a down
streak because something tells me that
it's gonna be all about how he gets back
up and i can't wait to see his next
trade hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time